each creation is an incarnation of the
one
god
is the active executive principle of
that one infinite absolute reality
the ultimate goal
is complete liberation and realization
of the one by itself
through the mirror of its own creation
through the illusion of an individual
soul
understanding the nature of
consciousness and how it may be
constituting reality or perception in
general
is crucial in being able to get to know
the truth
which you could call god or the mystery
of life
through an extremely intense longing or
desire for the absolute truth
infinite reality can know itself
that's the whole idea of
self-realization
purification or enlightenment
the individual merges back into its
unified god self
and finally
quantum leaps beyond that
into the absolute source
the less distorted the perception
the more the individuated mind begins to
see as god sees and be as god is
the more the mind knows its own essence
the closer it gets to experientially
apprehending god
how transparent we are to true love
depends on how much our individuated
mind sees as god sees
love is nothing but the innate
recognition of inseparability
when the one being recognizes itself in
apparent others
that is love
god is a unity of energy that is
unimaginably intelligent
conscious and sentient it's a living
field
we are distinct but not essentially
independent from one another
nor from the totality field of
consciousness
all bodies are plugged into a
motherboard
a unified field of existence
god is the free will or active
intelligence channeled from that
potential inherent in infinite reality
before anything can appear
there must be something
to which it appears
that is you
the entire creation
which seemingly contains billions of
years of evolution
is nothing but the blink of an eye
compared to the infinity of sources
absolute reality
would you want to know how to live well
within the matrix or would you want to
be unplugged
when you're outside of the virtual
reality the reality inside of the
virtual reality goggles appears as
non-existent to you because you're not
perceiving the illusion
as you put onto goggles
a veil of perception is pulled over your
eyes and now all of a sudden what was
not even felt or sensed as existent
appears in full
as if it exists
it appears to be real